[Music]
it is my pleasure now to welcome Hannah
H gray the Harry Pratt Judson
Distinguished Service professor of
history and president emeritus of the
University of Chicago professor gray
will now give the address good morning
there is a famous story famous at least
in the Connecticut River Valley about a
crusty patriotic old Vermonter who lived
on an island in the Connecticut River
the border between New Hampshire and
Vermont runs along there and one year a
team was sent out to survey it they
discovered quite unexpectedly that the
old man actually lived on the New
Hampshire side of the line and they set
out with considerable trepidation to
give him this news to their astonishment
he replied well thank the good Lord I
was beginning to think I'd never be able
to tolerate another of those goddamn
Vermont winters graduates of 1995 yours
is the exact analog to the old man's
situation the boundary that separates
you from another Boston winter has been
drawn you have been surveyed and found
to be Bachelors of Science masters of
science PhDs all those good things and
there are four citizens of some world
some state popularly known as the real
world yet tomorrow I suspect that your
spiritual terrain will be roughly the
same and so will you quite dramatically
unchanged if perhaps gratified to have
survived into your new citizenship but
in the meantime unkind fates have
decreed
and that your passage must be marked by
the right of the commencement speech let
me therefore begin by congratulating all
of you on whom degrees are being
conferred today and let me remind you
that my own presence here is meant to
keep this from happening too quickly for
that and the etiquette of these
occasions would be considered unseemly
you are meant to be restrained from
stampeding this platform in search of
your diplomas and from then rushing out
into the great world by the double
defense of your natural good manners and
my unnatural verbosity and this I can
reveal to you now is really the point of
the commencement speech its function is
to prolong the ceremony and to do so in
order to make it appear that something
has really happened here today as you
move on from the Institute you will move
on and at the same time you will always
retain your citizenship in this
university I hope that you will always
think of it not as an escape from the
world out there but as a real world too
without it the larger world and its
possibilities would be impoverished the
quality of its life its civilizing
values and social purposes impaired the
mission of this institute has to do with
learning along a broad spectrum of
undergraduate graduate and professional
study it has to do with learning a
scholarship with learning as the
discovery of knowledge it is concerned
with learning as the enjoyment of
knowledge of creativity in their
products it is directed to learning as
the initiation into a lifetime of taking
learning seriously taking seriously the
process of trying to come to some
understanding and wisdom of committing
to the obligation of thought of critical
judgment of the willingness to confront
complexity to examine assumptions to see
things in their
relationships and contexts and to engage
with in benefit from the thinking of
others these qualities are pertinent to
every activity of life every vocation
every decision every exercise of
citizenship and of responsible choice
the university exists for learning in
all these senses and it does so for the
long-term not for the pursuit of
immediate fad and fashion its existence
and its sustenance represent society's
continually renewed investment in its
future just as your education will have
no effective value unless you continue
to make its imperatives your own so the
university cannot thrive and play its
special role in serving society unless
you care for it and care for enabling
its moral and intellectual purposes
Robert Frost once said education doesn't
change life much it just it just lifts
trouble to a higher plane of regard and
that I suppose is one of the gifts and
one of the challenges bestowed on us as
thinking beings it would often be a lot
easier not to think as it would also be
easier not to try to see things whole or
to take into account new or different or
difficult or unsettling ways of
reviewing what we may have taken
comfortably for granted in attaining the
status of alumni you will of course be
eligible to receive copious
communications of great courtesy and
eloquence from the Institute rather
different in tone from those Stern
reminders that we did you in your
mailboxes here you will also find unless
you are very very careful that the
University will perhaps as early as
tomorrow begin to suffer a permanent
state of decline it is the common
experience of graduates that their
institution is never quite what it was
in their own day and in their memories
and that not to be the same or the place
of one's memory
is inevitably to be less in stature all
commentary on education a subject on
which everyone but everyone has very
strong and very stubborn opinions all
such commentary assumes that things are
generally getting worse in fact if you
have been listening at all too common to
current commentaries you would have to
believe that you cannot possibly have
been educated at all or educated nearly
as well as people used to be educated
and you may come and turn to believe
that your successors fate is even more
horrendous why is this why do people
forget the wise old saying that the
schools ain't what they used to be and
never was you will being at least more
or less educated recognize that this is
a rhetorical question as Sam Goldwyn put
it when I want your opinion I'll give it
to you I think the answer has a lot to
do with the ways in which education and
its institutions as they are thought
about get transformed into emblems of
other causes and hopes and fears it is
instructive to see how much of the
rhetoric having to do with the decline
of higher education derives from the
language of a larger nostalgia and from
romantic visions of a golden age that
never quite existed instructive to see
how much has to do with a resistance to
major changes that cannot be argued away
universities seen as institutions immune
to change and even caricatured for their
conservatism or at the same time
regarded especially not of course at MIT
but elsewhere by some of their alumni as
institutions that should not change and
that ought instead to preserve their own
past as they its loyalists wish to
remember it a timeless security against
the disintegrations and disappointments
the corruptions and uncertain turnings
of a threatening and fragmenting world
to the degree that universities mirror
the tensions and shifts within the
larger
society they become objects of the
disillusionment sand fears which those
evoke they appear as once safe places
suddenly made dangerous I'm not for a
moment arguing that there is not much to
strengthen and improve within higher
education but I am arguing that the
symbolic and selective uses of memory
and devotion have to be understood for
what they are before we can think
clearly about the state of Higher
Education and its institutions let me
give you just one example once upon a
time people say there was greater
harmony on our campuses whether true or
not it is certainly true that once upon
a time and not so long ago there was
greater homogeneity on our campuses and
surely to have a broadened diversity now
as a positive improvement and an
educational good our campuses as a
result have come to reflect more fully
some of the problematic tensions in our
society an academic community in which
those can be identified and discussed
and understood from different points of
view is in fact a better if not a more
comfortable place for learning than the
colleges of old but education is not
meant to be comfortable we forget that
too often it is not meant to be
comfortable
however enriching to think about
education is in fact to think about a
great deal more the debates over the
nature and uses of Education go far
beyond the questions of curriculum and
academic preparation ideals of Education
what it should be about what it should
be for how it's worth should be assessed
or in the end statements about the
future and the ideals we would wish to
see realized in that future statements
about human and social purpose and
possibility statements about the nature
of human society its needs and
aspirations statements about the
character and direction of civilized
existence
they are reflections too on the present
on its deficiencies and corruptions and
opportunities and reflections on the
past the lessons it provides to be
perpetuated or discarded and so to think
critically about education is to think
purposefully about the future in its
requirements and to be willing to accept
and to help shape the complexities of
change it is to create standards by
which to measure the quality of what
institutions represent over time in
light of the fundamental values by which
we hope to be guided it is to be
reminded that those institutions and
their enduring goals require continuing
renewal and that this depends on the
educated commitment of all their
citizens it is to develop one's vision
of hope and substantive purpose for the
generations to come
another important diversity in higher
education rests in the pluralism of our
system of higher education itself we
have many different kinds of
universities and colleges many different
kinds of opportunities and points of
entry many ways in which to afford
choice on the basis of their special
interests and talents and goals of the
particular institution in which students
and faculty decide to become members we
should resist the impulse toward
homogeneity toward which we are often
urged or driven by the rhetoric and
regulation of higher education and so
much else in our world the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology is an
institution of great distinction one in
whose uncompromising dedication to the
quality of its own mission you can
always take great pride in part because
it has had the courage and continuing
foresight to be clear about its own best
purposes and to adhere steadfastly to a
defined institutional personality that
lends shape and weight to its programs
of research and education so you will of
course see changes over time
but if they are the changes required to
sustain rather than to swerve from the
Institute's essential ethos that will be
a sign of health and strength not of
decline of course if you begin to see
the place offering debt courses or
division 1 football or an easy life we
will all have to think again and now as
you depart for the great world I will
leave you with one admonition drawn from
the philosopher Pete Seeger do you know
we asked the difference between
education and experience education is
when you read the fine print experience
is what happens when you don't I hope
for all of you that the fine print on
your diplomas will speak to a satisfying
and productive experience throughout
your lives one that will carry with it
good memories and continuing care for
what matters about your University
congratulations and good luck
you